[SPEAKER_00]: At 2 a.m. on the 5th of Walesun, Jude and Leslie follow Paul Ribeiro down the narrow winding staircase to the dungeons underneath Monmurg Palace.
[SPEAKER_00]: You enter the small jail area, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you see the two
[SPEAKER_00]: Scarlet Brotherhood agents, alleged Scarlet Brotherhood agents, in the cell, grabbing onto the bars and hissing at the five guards that are sitting there, obviously wary of them, with their crossbows loaded.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, even though the bars are there, you can tell that the guards are not comfortable in this situation.
[SPEAKER_00]: In the torchlight, you instantly notice, Jude,
[SPEAKER_00]: These people have been transformed in some way.
[SPEAKER_00]: They have fangs, and their eyes are very much like yours.
[SPEAKER_00]: Slits, snake-like in appearance.
[SPEAKER_00]: The beginnings of scales are actually apparent on the male's head.
[SPEAKER_00]: Both of them, however, don't look fully human.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's obvious why they wear masks.
[SPEAKER_00]: You roll a nit check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Rack and roll a 20.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus your intelligence.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is intelligence modifier, which is plus four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are the transformed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absalon, your master, has talked about creatures like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Yontai.
[SPEAKER_00]: People transformed into snakes with the minds of snakes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The transmuters from the east would do this to people to make them slaves.
[SPEAKER_02]: When I walked up, there was two of them standing out in the front, and then the chickens and the people came out, and they just walked down, like, not even a full block into the next building, literally.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you just followed them, then you got some guys and you apprehended them?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's funny what you can do with a handful of Marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's funny what you can do with a handful of slaves.
Chemicals.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sometimes I catch too many fumes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sometimes I don't see fumes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I grab a torch.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just ignore him.
[SPEAKER_01]: I grab a torch off the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to go look at whichever one is the female.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do they have the female that's like kept with the... No, they're in two different cells.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is there only three total?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's only two.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're both like grabbing the bars and just hissing like crazy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is one of them a female?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude picks his lantern up and tries to sit in her face.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm trying to like kind of see if I like, you know, from a distance, about the same size, height, profile.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's about human.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it's human sized.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like the one that was in the sewage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what I'm afraid of.
[SPEAKER_01]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at the guards.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have they said anything in common?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are they just kissing?
[SPEAKER_00]: The guard looks at you sideways and goes, They speak some language, but I have no idea what it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I assume it's insults.
[SPEAKER_00]: I say something insulting.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you say?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like, you know, you're gonna grow a tail that's two inches long.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something like that, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can you say that to the woman?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: She says, You've failed, you foolish elf, in Ancient Soul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_01]: I look at the mail.
[SPEAKER_00]: The alchemist is dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is the mail listening?
[SPEAKER_01]: Like he's tracking?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, he's tracking the conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Which one do you want to start with first?
[SPEAKER_01]: What I would suggest is that we tie them down, milk their fucking fangs, because I would bet you money that that's part of the poison.
[SPEAKER_01]: Guards!
[SPEAKER_00]: They're all right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you say to them?
[SPEAKER_02]: Get me something, get me a crow, or get me some pliers.
[SPEAKER_01]: This guy probably knows the thing that we need.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the slave catcher.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's got a loop at the end of the pole.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get one of those two.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a net.
[SPEAKER_03]: A net pole.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like a Pokemon catcher.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a Pokemon catcher.
[SPEAKER_01]: That way, when we rip their fangs out, you've actually got some poison that you can work with.
[SPEAKER_01]: You gotta work with what you got.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want us to use their own poison to poison them?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not at all.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just meant when we rip their fangs out, it's not gonna be pretty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't realize they were poisonous.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, is that how they bite and then he... Well, I'm sure they can tear you apart, too, or stab you with, like, weapons and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just saying, anything with fangs, it looks like it's growing scales.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'd be surprised if you didn't draw some poison from it.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can't tell you how poisonous it's gonna be, but...
[SPEAKER_03]: So wait, are we hiring snakes as our slaves?
[SPEAKER_03]: There are so many options that could be way better than snakes that... they don't even have arms.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, first off, these ones still have arms.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have not yet lost their arms.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're telling me you can just tell a snake to lift a 50-ton block?
[SPEAKER_03]: Who can lift a 50-ton block?
[SPEAKER_03]: A lot of slaves can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Look, no, we're not gonna make them slaves.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're gonna torture them and then kill them.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's unnecessary.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because you want them as slaves?
[SPEAKER_01]: Workers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you mean test subjects.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what you mean.
[SPEAKER_01]: Workers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll tell you about Dr. Mangala.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dude, I'm gonna, like, kick you out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Restrain yourself, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's pile on.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want these two fuckers milked.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, the guards, the jailer says, I know just this thing Master Jude is speaking of.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he walks into the back room and brings out this pole with a clamp on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, you guys watch as he wrangles, because which one first?
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's do the female first.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, let's do the male.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: For sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then we'll see if the female...
[SPEAKER_02]: What she'll do.
[SPEAKER_02]: She won't give a shit about the mail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, the fact.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what the book says.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go on.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, basically, he takes the catcher, the man catcher, and wrangles the guy who doesn't have very much room to maneuver in the cell.
[SPEAKER_00]: Grasping him around the neck with it and then pulling the claws tight.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then he tries to pull him towards the bars but it's obvious he's not strong enough and a guard has to go in there and help him.
[SPEAKER_00]: But they get the guy pulled up against the bars and he's like got his arms out trying to grasp whatever he can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately that just gives the other guards the chance to go in there and
[SPEAKER_00]: Grab him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And soon they have his arms held and they use that to open the door and go in from behind and manacle him that way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep, and manacles behind the back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't want them in front.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's get his feet shackled.
[SPEAKER_00]: So basically Jude directs as they bring this guy low and get him completely chained and tied up with tight manacles that only give that much room behind his back so he cannot move.
[SPEAKER_00]: Under the jailer's direction, they move him into another room.
[SPEAKER_00]: An empty nondescript room with a drain on the floor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does it have a table, or do I have to get down on my knees?
[SPEAKER_00]: It doesn't have a table, but they put one chair in there and set him down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hand me those clipper-looking pliers.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_01]: Hook his nose.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you walk in there, and who's in this room with you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you watching, Leslie?
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you watching?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he's in there with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Leslie sits in the corner.
[SPEAKER_01]: We bind him to the chair first off, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: So not as many as he shackled a manapal, if he tries to spring up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, I'm shackled?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's all, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dude, wake up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was planning.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what I want to do is I want to force him to open his mouth and I'm going to stick a tongue grabber thingy in his mouth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, so as Paul watches, one of the guards at your request grabs this guy by the head and pulls his head back and then uses his meaty hand.
[SPEAKER_00]: To ply his mouth open.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exposing his fangs.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to brace it so that he can't close.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to use one of my, you know, sample vials.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I'm going to milk them and see if anything comes out.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you milk the fangs.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pale green liquid.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Goes into the vials.
[SPEAKER_00]: Both of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cap it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You get about that much stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.